surfing's sort of a necessary part of
life
for me it represents balance
I find that it's less about actually
surfing and it's more about getting into
the ocean and washing everything away
it's that time alone with my thoughts
there's something about getting an
amazing wave it hooks you where it's
like oh I got to get another one of
those that was too good right
surfing came from Hawaii it isn't this
thing that just as a Beach Boys
phenomenon or something that just
happened in the 60s it's actually
thousands of years old
Randy and I were both vintage freaks and
when we really come together it's on
vintage surf we just kept talking about
how can we build a brand with all of
this beautiful history and Miranda is
famous for throwing something in front
of me like check this out
and one of those days was the original
Makaha drown or trunk it was a surf swap
meet and it was laying like this right
boom this is an Amiga shores custom port
sharks and I heard that I just keep
doubt on it for like an hour
this beautiful seam the way you see that
curve the stitches per inch had this
amazing Windansea patch on it Windansea
surf club was a very elite club we found
this photo all of these guys have their
surf club jacket on man those guys got
game I just wanted I want a piece of
what's in that photo right and he's
literally wearing this jacket this photo
and this trunk was really our
jumping-off point for the brand and then
it just became this love affair
I didn't know the history about me at
that point it was a beautiful label
beautiful trunk I wanted to build a
brand the MDE shop was on the west side
of Oahu where the biggest waves are is
Makaha right there that's where it all
started
ami was founded in 1948 by neuro and his
wife Florence it was a husband and wife
team they were making band uniforms so
they had heavier 12 fabrics decorative
tapes there was whole surf clubs wearing
em before and they need some of the
earliest legends of Surfing the surfing
in cut-offs
you know these trunks were like in
badging Ohana they were built better
than anything any of these surfers could
get their hands on anywhere else
anytime a luminary would go through the
islands they hear about these helm and
chasing these waves and these cool
trunks and you'd bring home a pair of
trunks - I think the whole story behind
me he is a really romantic story this is
a faux of the actual tailor and we get
relay that same message and the passion
and I think to their customer really
responds to them - one two three
they kind of have that retro feel but
they still feel modern at the same time
and it's such a classic garment that
anyone could wear it
I think our guy appreciates the finer
things he's not a flamboyant fashion
victim you think he just appreciates
great quality and craftsmanship
I sensed personally that my generation
was all searching for meaning we wanted
something that had a sense of purpose in
history storytelling is it relates to
fashion I think he's really illuminating
that deeper meaning into something but I
think it can be where something is made
how something is made and I think we
really invest in working with people
we're trying to be consistent and
deliver beautiful products season after
season right in our backyard
and the main clutch and we've done that
in melton wall there's a lot of nuance
to any our colors can be bold but our
designs are subtle
it's not like a knock you over the head
oh my gosh that's avant-garde fashion
it's the subtlety of a stitch we call
them thoughtful details
surfing has always been about that
intangible cool people try to define it
but I don't think you can so I think
that's kind of what we're doing is
trying to bring that intangible cool
back into the marketplace with a real
sense of soul and purpose